meine größten stärken sind dass ich zu
hören kann dass ich helfen möchte immer
unterstützen und dass sich
lösungsorientiert bin und nicht immer
drum herum reden will
mein name ist philipp wesemann und ich
bin hauptamtlicher bürgermeister der
kreis und rosenstadt forst lausitz
ich bin moderator aber auch derjenige
der sagt in welche richtung sich die
stadt entwickeln soll
wenn die mauer nicht gefallen wird dann
würde ich wahrscheinlich hier in forst
auch leben nur mit dem ganz anderen
beruf häufig zumindest dass ich ihn
force gewesen wäre und mich nicht dem
regime unterdrückt hätte nur dass sich
politik machen kann
zu ddr zeiten hätte philipp wesemann
keine wahl gehabt
wer eine politische karriere wollte
musste mitglied der sozialistischen
einheitspartei werden seit mai ist er im
amt und mit 25 der jüngste bürgermeister
seines bundeslandes brandenburg anfang
50 brille schon gesetzter mann der so
knallhart ist das ist so dieses typische
bild vom bürgermeister was man glaube
ich hat zumindest ist es mein eindruck
wenn wenn leute überrascht tun dass sich
der bürgermeister bin bin kein klischee
25-jähriger wenn dann schon souverän
genug mit den leuten normal zu sprechen
auch ernsthaft zu sprechen wie die ideen
anzuhören meine vorstellungen darzulegen
das haben sie sich vorgestellt die
dachten wahrscheinlich dass ich ein
verrückter 25-jähriger der jetzt mal vor
hat bürgermeister zu werden
forst eine stadt mit knapp 20.000
einwohnern gelegen im osten deutschlands
an der grenze zu polen
am 30 september 1989 wenige wochen vor
dem mauerfall kommt für die wesemann
hier zur welt
ein hobby das er als teenager entdeckt
das dudelsack spielen dabei trainiert er
sich den langen atem an dem man als
politiker braucht nach der ausbildung
zum biologie laboranten in berlin
dritter in seiner heimatstadt in die
sozialdemokratische partei ein und wird
mit 21 vorsitzender des ortsvereins vier
jahre später gewinnt er die wahl zum
neuen chef im rathaus
das amt des bürgermeisters bringt vieles
mit sich mit unter anderem dass man kaum
noch privatleben hat also man kann
einfach nicht mehr dann so locker mit
freunden in restaurants sitzen und mal
laut lachen und das meiner komisch
angeguckt wird man kann auch nicht mehr
so zu den supermarkt gehen und einkaufen
ohne dass jemand einen einkaufswagen
guckt ging und das ist für einen
25-jährigen schon großer einschnitt
die wichtigsten dinge im leben sind die
freundin die familie und ich glaube
einfach nur glücklich sein
mittagspause zusammen mit seiner besten
freundin sarah und seinem partner
stephan die beziehung zu ihm hat philipp
wesemann nie versteckt auch nicht im
wahlkampf die kommen einfach nicht damit
so zurecht dass man damit umgeht und
sage lieber gar nichts sie sich
blamieren und andere leute die es
einfach so hin
wir sehen uns als normal an der nächste
termin findet wiesemann empfängt eine
delegation älterer spd-mitglieder und
führt sie durch die stadtgeschichte
sie sind zu besuch aus lüneburg im
ehemaligen westteil deutschlands
jeder von ihnen hat den großteil seines
lebens in einem geteilten land verbracht
man sieht die generation die dafür
gekämpft hat es die einheit kommt die
schaut sich die sache schon so anja ist
es gut aber irgendwie gibt es auch
nachteile
und auch noch ein bisschen vorteile und
dann bei der jetzigen generation
verwischt schon wieder das ist schon
wieder ganz andere anders denken was ich
so im freundeskreis mitbekomme redet man
gar nicht über ossi und wessi sondern
über deutsche und bayern sich wie
philipp wesemann in einer partei zu
engagieren ist eher untypisch für junge
deutsche
laut einer repräsentativen umfrage im
auftrag von euromax engagiert sich etwa
jeder dritte der 1989 90 geborenen
gesellschaftlich oder politisch
die meisten von ihnen arbeiten mit
kindern und jugendlichen oder engagieren
sich im sport nur 16 prozent bringen
sich politisch 1 14 prozent bei kirchen
und gemeinden philipp wesemann will die
bürgerbeteiligung wieder erhöhen und die
jugend in seiner stadt erreichen als
kind seine generation setzt er dabei auf
soziale netzwerke wie facebook
mitnehmen also schon die möglichkeit
geben das ist deine heimatstadt setzt
sich gefällig sinn und entscheide mit